congratulations on the film thank you
very much have you seen it I saw it I
saw without music and I saw without some
of the effects finished and everything
so I'll see it in a couple days cool
yeah but what what do you think so far
it's it's just the sort of film I've
always wanted to be in you know I still
feel it's for a film that I've always
wanted to watch it that I see care all
the time so to be in one of them is
amazing anyway what is it about it that
you know as actually as an audience
member that you like then it's just so
gripping I mean I Alex who wrote and
directed it obviously is he's just I
think he might be my favorite you know
like I think he's there cause my phone
oh this is my favorite basically so that
the it's just so gripping from second to
second it's so interesting um and it
just keeps on changing what you think as
it goes on you keep on thinking I
understand what's happening with these
people and you absolutely don't it just
grabs you in and there's no there's no
let-up it's just this exactly yeah it's
exactly the sort of feeling my love so
it's pretty cool yeah it's very cool
everybody is let's start the beginning
talk about Caleb who you play yeah
describe him for us um he is a coder he
works for an internet search engine kind
of the biggest one in the world so an
equivalent of one that we are all aware
of but uh he he's a sort of a normal guy
pretty secluded and very just into his
work it feels like and then he wins this
lottery to spend a week with the owner
of the company who's a genius so he so
he goes out to be with him and with no
idea of what to expect and has thrown
into the middle of this madness where he
doesn't know exactly what's going on
from second to second and things keep on
changing around him so he's I know if
he's a fish out of water in us but he's
he's in over his head pretty quick and
he's trying you know he's trying to
understand
and his situation as it goes on and I
think he's a pretty normal guy I think
put in really exceptional circumstances
now Oscar plays Nathan though the
billionaire content recluse yeah that
owns this amazing place where he goes
yeah
and when your character is there he
meets Ava doesn't he yeah tell us about
her Ava is the I mean the most
incredible thing that man has invented
which is another consciousness so that's
never happened before so the test is
he's brought you know the guys is to see
whether she's conscious or not I suppose
that's Caleb's job that he's put to and
but pretty quickly he starts seeing her
as a human almost even though it's so
clear that she's not I mean you can see
the way she works you can see her her
face is the face of a human but
everything around her is so clearly
robotic but she's beautiful there's a
purity to her and there's a um she's
just special in so many different ways
and exceptional in so many different
ways so he he's fascinated by her in
every way I think as a robot as a human
as a consciousness and and as and as a
woman which obviously complicates things
further he Nathan asked him to carry
what's what's known as the Turing test
yeah could you explain that for us
because the Turing test as is put in the
film I think pretty early on so
everybody knows what's going on and the
shirring test is normally done
differently the Turing test is normally
a person and then a tester and then
they're in a room by themselves normally
it's just done by tapping into a
computer and then getting replies asking
questions of somebody or of a computer
on the other side of the wall you're
allowed to ask questions for a certain
amount of time they give you answers and
at the end of it you're supposed to
guess whether it's a human or a computer
giving you these responses
and it's never been past really and so
that's the way it's normally doing you
don't know what's on the other side of
the curtain but in this this one is
different this Turing test is different
the rules are different because he's
able to see what's in front of him and
he's able to see that it is a robot so
the Turing test is tweaked in that he
has to try and understand or decide for
himself whether he thinks is a
consciousness in there and so that's how
the Turing test is different in this one
okay and obviously that the
repercussions of a machine having a real
mind and real feelings as well all the
stuff that goes with being conscious is
a it's very complicated and it's very
difficult but she's so clearly present
she's so clearly she's got a sense of
humor she's got a sense of decency of
right and wrong all these things which
computers don't have and so things
escalate very quickly in terms of what
it means to keep somebody locked up if
it is a person or if it is a or if it is
conscious
you know how okay it is to keep
something like that locked up so the
film is dealing with some very big
things here hmm and some very topical
themes I mean I'm sure you saw professor
Stephen Hawking's comments hmm about AI
and how if we do develop it it will
quickly advance to the point where we
become kind of redundant or we can't
control it well we can't control it well
what were your thoughts on it going in
and did it change during the process of
making the film I think it changes all
the time because there's always this
doomsday scenario which is put on the
notion of of true artificial
intelligence which is if we can't
control it then we shouldn't create it
and because you shouldn't create
something you can't control
but really I think with the part of the
film is up is about evolution which is
if you create something which is
superior then should you control it
maybe you shouldn't maybe you should
create it and then let it do its own
thing if it is in fact superior and but
as a human you want control
everybody wants control over themselves
and to a certain extent over other
people to whether you like to admit it
or not and so that the balance of that
shifts all the time during the film and
while we were filming it the balance of
it shifted all the time in my head -
yeah of course of course
because the notion of something being a
threat you never want to create a threat
but if it's superior than its superior
and maybe you're supposed to be a threat
you know like those things add up all
the time and kind of hit him to each
other quite hard and especially if
you're right at the center of it of
deciding whether it should be yeah
allowed to exist or not it's I I
actually don't know still where I stand
on it cuz that alex has a very clear
view he and I'm sure you've spoken to
him about you know it is the natural
notes next step and he believes it will
happen within he said to me within his
lifetime do you think were that close
well I mean I I'm not qualified to know
that because I don't actually code and I
don't actually create those sort of you
know I barely passed maths at school so
I I'm the last person to know
but is it kerza like I curse all he
thinks it'll hi he he's coming with the
date of many things it'll happen and for
a year when he thinks it will happen and
he seems to think of it as a positive
thing but it is you know I know so
little about the reality of it that I'm
not sure the singularity the moment of
senior you know I don't know yeah I've
no clue no clue did you have to do some
research to play this character and you
say genomic massive school school level
math I'll imagine yeah you know we will
use these computers and phones smart
phones and things but yeah most of us
have no idea how they work no and while
we were filming and all that stuff came
out about people search histories being
forever you know and the way you know
Google's not gonna like you but you know
the way your search results are based on
your previous search results and it
creates a personality of you basically
and then feeds it back to you
you know so when you search for
something it will take into account
everything
you've previously searched or clicked on
and everything it will present you with
those things with your favorites at the
top of what it thinks will be your favor
so actually it's not just its own it
doesn't just cover in itself it creates
a version of you every time you search
for something those things are really
terrifying but also really handy if you
write in the name of you know a local
Indian restaurant if you write in just
the name of the restaurant will come up
with your local restaurant as opposed to
someplace in India you know so it's
handy yeah but you don't know how much
control you've given over so it's um
yeah it's complicated and I guess I have
no idea I have no idea where I am in all
this or alex is so much more clear on
that stuff than I am you know he's very
clear yeah let's talk about is because
you've worked together before of course
yeah you know each other for a few years
some of you yeah brilliant
had he talked to you because again he
was telling me that this is a project
that he's been thinking about for a
number of years hmm you guys talked
about it maybe before or no I'd never
talked to Alex about it before he it's
for I mean this these are the stories
you tell when you when you talk about
something too much maybe but then I got
an email from Alex we haven't been in
touch a lot
I don't read with him and never let me
go which I was very proud to be in those
two films and then I got an email from
him saying I've got something you may be
interested in and sent to this and said
you want to talk about it send me the
script adored
I mean adored the script read in one go
no I mean like I was doing a different
job you know I I probably shouldn't have
been reading other projects and I
thought I'll read a guy it's Alex so I'm
just in just him you could potentially
just ya know and then you're just all
night you know I mean reading it a
couple of times and and then I did and
then I did get invited over to his house
I went over to do the audition tape
because he said he wanted me to do it
but you have to get people to yeah you
know all that stuff and so in a way it
was like Caleb going over to Nathan's I
think you know this person who you
really admire who is at the very top of
what they do off the thing that you do
who's at the very top and inviting you
over and it was kind of like winning
that lottery going over not none
you're letting yourself in for and and
he everything was in the script we
talked plenty about it because the ideas
are so huge but my everything I always
to the character you know into the film
and that was just so clear on the page
once you get to the end of what you have
to put into the beginning I thought it
was amazing and so I was just dying to
be a part of it basic did you when when
you were first with him you know a few
years ago hmm
did you know them that he would direct
himself did you think yeah he's gonna
direct at some point I thought he should
I didn't know if he would uh it was very
clear to me that he was more than not
just capable but you know he has a gift
with writing and he's able to shepherd
that so clearly and get the best out of
everybody on a film set so and not
easily I'm sure it's difficult but he
just he gets the best out of everybody
at what they do I think on this film in
particular I think every department I'll
be surprised if anybody wouldn't put
this film at the top of what they've
done you know and that's across the
board from makeup to CG to the
photography to everybody and so it was
clear to me that he was a lot more than
capable and I hoped he would and and
then when he did I was looking after he
asked me to be involved so it was a
perfect scenario of me me and he had a
rehearsal period I believe in what was
that rehearsal period I which I'm
important in kind of working out those
dynamics between the three characters
and how that plays because it it is very
much a three piece I know there are two
other characters in it we see but you
guys aren't you carried the weight of
the movie yes yeah I think that's fair
to say yeah and the rehearsal period
it wasn't the rehearsal period was
pretty straightforward right you know I
did like I say when the script is that
good if you give everything to it and
everybody cares which everybody did and
I think it's difficult to really mess it
up if everyone's honest and everyone is
talented and Oscar and Alyssia are
obviously
credibly talented and and Alex was so
clear about what it needed to be that we
zipped through it pretty quickly and the
levels reveal themselves of course but I
think we all knew was going to be there
so building up those relationships I
already had a relationship with Melissa
had worked with her previously and
thought she was a wonderful that has
long anna karenina yes yes that's right
yeah and we'd worked very well on that I
felt like we really had a strong
connection with the work and with each
other and how to get the best out of
each other so I felt like we were in
solid ground there even though this
relationship is so different yeah and
and then Oscar is a completely different
sort of being and we had our own way of
working that through too and so really
is about finding editors processes I
already knew alyssia's finding at Oscars
probably you know from their sense like
such as actory word but the way people
work just finding it the way he works
with how to work with somebody that was
really what it felt to me that that the
rehearsal period was about I think and
working with Oscar he's a he's wonderful
in this you all yeah yeah he's fantastic
was that because in the way your
character is is the audience we enter
the world through you don't we yeah and
we meet them both mainly through you yes
yeah and you had that relationship with
the militia but Oscar was a new guy for
you I presume yes yeah I lemon LuAnn
Davis nice tough yes yeah
he was fantastic you know he brought a
certain amount of the certainty that
nathan has you know and that kind of the
oddness of Nathan I think Oscar carried
it around a little bit sometimes when we
were there and I carried around a little
bit of kie it's inevitable it always
happens a little bit of bleeds in and
he's very very very funny man Oscar you
know very fun to be around but once we
can unbirth a really good fun then once
we got to filming we still had a laugh
and everything but there was I think a
certain amount of that battle you know
in a really really good way for the film
that was going on of you're never able
to truly know what the other person was
thinking really yeah you know digging in
was quite difficult because
does this veneer of is he lying or is he
telling the truth all the time and I
thought he did it brilliantly he's
fantastic it was intense
yeah yeah I found it very intense yeah I
found it very intense but rewarding is
well clearly the reward is in the film
you know like there was a lot of fun on
set but they were but it was you know it
was an enclosed environment alone at the
time we were in those small rooms you
know you could feel the psychological
pressure there long scenes that are very
back and forth and wandering and what
the hell are you doing to me and what am
i doing to you and all those sort of
things
so there was a huge amount of intensity
there but it just meant it was fun to
break out of it when you could then you
know Alex was always popping over and
telling me that if I did the next scene
well enough that he would give me his
watch it was powerful is watching his
hands like this could be yours if you
really loved this next take and that was
a nice watch
but yeah so it was like you know we were
laughing the whole time what it was
always always about getting the scene he
was always forgetting the sinks is quite
a quick shoot
you